what's up king of the sting family
i got a quick uh question for you guys
would you rather
live to 30 years old and be a
millionaire and do whatever you want
or live to a hundred and just be an
average joe
gang gang buzz buzz oh i think
everyone's trying to see if we're going
to die
we don't know it's crazy if we both die
after this episode
yeah they released my physical results
what's going on here baby unique what
would you say to that one
baby unique i'm gonna die at 30 i guess
because i definitely want to accomplish
all my goals and be the magical shining
star i know i am sorry
there i go at 30. yeah maybe nick is
dead
at least i accomplished all my goals
yeah i mean at least they'll say that at
the funeral you know
they won't be like damn that [ __ ] was
sexy and didn't do [ __ ]
she was sexy and she got [ __ ] done there
you go yeah
she got everything now she even died
they really like damn she got it all
done
yeah um nick what do you think there
uh i think that's tough
uh because i i like just earning money
as like a like almost a game like keep
score
like can that's why you're a gambler can
you keep growing and stuff but
uh like i said extremely afraid of death
over here so
i think maybe live to 100 poor i'd live
a hundred poor i got kids
i'd rather be poor and see them do their
thing how about putting it on your kids
i'm gonna go with them i'm sorry my bad
i'm just saying bro kids with no dad
[ __ ] grow up hard bro
you know what i'm saying i don't want to
grow up hard dude your [ __ ] kids
could grow up skateboarding with a
[ __ ] white family bro yeah i don't
want that
okay you're saying bro what do you mean
you don't want chappelle as a son
yeah you don't want me as a son you know
me as a son damn right damn
wow what do you want to do shabel
hundred or diet third [ __ ] hundred
i like to learn i like learning i like
exploring let's do it you go in the
distance huh yeah
i would go 30 and uh and have gotten it
all done i just think there's something
amazing about dying young bro
there's just something like you know
nobody give like if somebody dies at 55
nobody really gives
like it's like oh [ __ ] they died you
know they were about to
yeah like not oh they died a little bit
you know but if you died at 19 well
you're a [ __ ]
legend no 27 is the number if you want
to be famous
yeah really jimi hendrix morrison corker
bane
ever like that i feel like you're
getting awesome
something from uh uh philippi from the
rolling stones i think
ron phillippi how how old was uh how old
was uh paul walker
i don't know thirty-something minutes
but there's that they called the 27 club
though
amy winehouse was a part of it yeah yeah
you look a little latino amy winehouse
like amy michelada house huh
[Music]
is